first here with reaction all this saga
she is the host of crime stories right
on foxnation.com our own nancy grace is
with us nancy uh first of all i don't
see any winners here to start with and
secondly i i look at the utter evil
brutality darkness use every adjective
you can think of
and i know that these situations arise
my advice to anybody if you find
yourself in one get out as soon as
possible don't pass go do not collect
200 leave immediately thoughts
well as to the verdict that has just
come down in the last hours as i said at
the get-go it's like two wet cats in the
barrel the only question was which one
is going to crawl out on top of the
other in this case depp crawled out on
top and i can tell you another thing
sean hannity it would be a cold day in
double
h-e-l
that i or would let my daughter stay in
a relationship where somebody cavity
searched me for drugs and raped me with
a wine bottle that's not gonna happen
bye bye out but she didn't leave gotta
wonder why right now she has issued a
statement saying basically
let me let me david let me introduce let
me nancy nancy let me interrupt you a
second so the jury obviously didn't buy
that because if they did they would have
come to a different verdict here so my
question is that's right it sounds like
you did believe that is that true
what i just said was if
someone had body cavity searched me for
drugs or rape me with a wine bottle i'd
be gone
i wouldn't stay around but she did which
in my mind negates the claim
i find that very fantastical to believe
and for her to now say this was a david
and goliath story where she is cast as
david and depp as goliath
that somehow she couldn't fight all of
his power and sway
that's not her undoing her undoing was
her own lies in front of the jury you
can't go into court and expect that
everything about you is not going to be
exposed because it will be and it's a
matter of this i'm not saying sean
hannity that this is a popularity
contest nobody's going to be crowned
miscongeniality that's not going to
happen
but when a jury can smell your lies
they don't like you and they're not
going to believe anything you say and i
believe they could smell her lies hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else